We've so far
described abstractly
what we mean by a dot
product, by a definition of AB
equals the magnitude of
A times cosine theta,
times the magnitude of B. But
many times in physics problems,
we actually have
vectors in space
and we want to
see how to do this
in terms of a Cartesian
or any coordinate system
in particular.
So let's set up a coordinate
system, we'll call it
Cartesian, a and j.
And now this is very important.
Let's define a vector A here,
and let's have another vector
in a completely different point,
B. We still can take the dot
product of these two vectors.
But in order-- this
is our plus x, plus y.
And I'm only doing
things in two dimensions.
So how do we calculate
the dot product?
Well, the first thing
that we want to look at
is our unit vectors.
What are the dot
products of unit vectors?
Well, if we take i hat dot i
hat, that's the magnitude of i
hat times cosine of the angle
0, times the magnitude of i hat.
And cosine of 0 is 1 and the
magnitude of unit vectors
are 1.
So when you dot product the unit
vector with itself, you get 1.
And therefore, it's also
true for the j hat. j
hat dot j hat is 1.
What happens when you
dot product two vectors
that are perpendicular?
Well, in this case, this is
0 because the angle theta
is 90 degrees.
And remember that cosine
of 90 degrees is 0.
And anyway, when two
vectors are perpendicular,
there's no component
of one vector
that's parallel to the other.
So these are the
essential facts that we're
going to need to calculate the
dot product of two vectors that
are separated in space.
So the way we do that is we'll
begin by drawing, writing down
the vectors in Cartesian
coordinates, where
Ax A is a scalar and the vector
part is and the unit vector.
And we have Ay j hat.
And likewise, we can write
B as Bx i hat plus By j hat.
And now when we take the dot
product of these two vectors,
we're going to write
out all the terms
here so that you see them.
So here is our scalar
or dot product.
We use those words
interchangeably.
Now notice that
we've already shown
that the dot product distributes
over vector addition.
And also, if you multiply
a scalar by a vector,
you can pull the scalar out.
So there's four terms here--
Ax i hat dot Bx i hat plus ax
i hat dot By j hat plus
Ay j hat dot Bx i hat.
This is a little
tedious to write out.
By j hat.
And now because
these are scalars,
we can pull them out and the
only part of a dot product
that matters is how
the unit vectors dot.
And that's why we have
these two results.
i hat dot i hat is 1,
j hat dot j hat is 1,
and i hat dot j hat is 0.
So the first turn is Ax Bx.
i hat dot j hat is 0,
so we don't need that.
j hat dot i hat is 0.
And finally j hat
dot j hat is 1.
And so we get plus Ay By.
And that's how we
define the dot product
in Cartesian coordinates
of two vectors.
Now, notice that if
we dotted a vector,
A dot with itself, that would
just be Ax Ax plus Ay Ay, which
is the components squared.
And that's equal
to the magnitude
of the vector squared.
And so we can say that the
magnitude of the vector,
of any vector, is you take
its dot product with itself.
You take the square
root, but remember
we always take the positive
square root, because magnitudes
are positive.
And that's how we calculate
the scalar product for vectors.
And many times in the
application of physics,
when we have physical
quantities that
are vectors in different places,
we use vector decomposition
and we use this procedure.
This is the Cartesian
picture, we'll
learn how to do that
in polar coordinates
when we need it later on.